voilà nous sommes sur le pont avec
georges asbeck dire pile des civils sont
évacués on peut voir des combats de plus
en plus proche il ya des salves de tirs
d'artillerie très rapproché nous n'avons
pas depuis trois jours tout bon ici
cette expérience de tirs d'artillerie
extrêmement proches qui sont des tirs
diffus je sais pas s'il pouvait entendre
des salves très importante de tirs
d'artillerie ce que nous disent les
forces spéciales qui sont en train
d'arriver et les forces spéciales
ukrainienne qui passe ce pont pour
accélérer le l'évacuation des civils
pouvaient voir des fumées noires qui ce
qui s'échappe des prémices dire pin la
ville nouvelle d'hier pid donc on a
changé vraiment de degré de violence
donc les forces spéciales nous disent
que les tanks russes sont dans la grande
avenue qui se trouve à date 2 ou 3 km de
là ou autres où on avait passé vraiment
à un autre degré d'intensité des combats
pouvait voir même les prêtres des
prêtres orthodoxes sont venus pour
secourir les réfugiés l'exode accélère
dix mille personnes ont pu être évacuées
hier de cette région aujourd'hui les
combats ont repris avec une intensité ce
qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis le début
c'est réellement maintenant devenu une
pure zone de guerre nous sommes à 15 km
du centre ville de kef